physicists and foundations of physics  rely on beauty to discover the next best  fundamental law they think that the  foundations of physics the way that we  currently have them as as with general  relativity and the standard model are  just not pretty enough  these theories leave them wanting for  various reasons for example in the  standard model we have three different  types of interactions there is the  electromagnetic interaction that most of  you will probably have heard of and then  there is the strong and the weak nuclear  force but these kind of sit next to each  other in a quite awkward way and it  would be much prettier if they were  ultimately all three aspects of one  large interaction that would be  described by a one symmetry group so  this is what is called a grant unified  theory and it's just aesthetically much  more appealing